i don't know do you know what i'm gonna
be honest would you prefer
guys or girls um
[Applause]
welcome back to the waffle
yeah the last one the last time he was
out was what max yeah we had mike's
comedy last time so i hope you lot
enjoyed that that one was mad yeah man
are all coming on there talking about
sharing bum bum in class
go through a madness say i'm gonna get
bullied punch up in the school but he's
a real one still yeah anyway
um i'm drinking right now it looks like
milkshake blood and my man's trying to
offer it to me you know dessert or
velvet like mm-hmm or liquor this is
going to mess me up if i start slurring
my words later i'm already
creamy i'm probably going to end up on
the toilet but it tastes good i'll let
everyone else know if he's farting up
because i won't be sat here yeah you
know about our [ __ ] oh chris
you get me this is wavy though got this
from kf yeah a little lime and i've
never tasted that before lime lime water
yeah man that's some alcohol in that
bread off we've got
the wonderful the beautiful
yeah the fashionable do you get me she's
an artist as well
um beautiful she does her ting man that
she's one of the she's like the mandom
as well as the gundam do you get me that
i can relate with her man she that's why
so much people love her because she's
just got that good energy with energy
she brought up some bad weight tunes as
well yeah yeah so i don't even want to
give away nothing but no further ado the
one and only
pagey cakey
i'm not gonna lie that was a gassy
entrance yeah yeah yeah i was listening
yeah i was listening like i like it i
like it it's hard you made me feel good
yeah that's cool that's what i needed so
how are you doing paige i'm good your
name just ouch here nice nice nice
trying to be healthy anything healthy
well i mean i've just whacked off their
doritos all right so you say you're into
the health stuff right
well how much because i'm a personal
trainer yeah right so how much do you
know what what's good health to you a
healthy mind
okay okay okay
that's that's the most important healthy
mind healthy body
um eating greens drinking water
exercising sleeping well and do you
train well now i'm just running 5k every
day and skating really so yeah every day
yeah doesn't that hurt or do you get
bored of it or are you bored i hate it
yeah it's all the way
i hate running just because people see
me running don't mean i enjoy it i just
like what you get from me yeah that i
feel good and i just feel like
i feel good in my body in it
good feeling afterwards yeah did you do
weights or anything like that i was like
i was going gym and all that recently
i've just cut out all of that because
i don't have a trainer and i just
sometimes i feel like it's pointless i
go gym and i'll start lifting weights
and i'm just like what am i doing that's
why i said you need to holler at me
i don't i don't go there i know what i'm
doing i just walk around see what's
green
don't get me wrong i know what i'm doing
but i'd rather spend my time in the park
where the mats are where you do like
depending on team yeah yeah other than
that i don't have a plan people are
working
that's good i'll bid you up for that man
are you happy
yeah yeah yeah and why that's mad do you
know it yeah the way really said that i
wasn't
happy she said she said it she said that
you have to say that right why do you
ask me this is a trick question
nah it ain't a trick question we watch
that all the time oh do you know what if
you asked me maybe like a week and a
half ago yeah i wasn't happy okay but i
am very happy right now like i feel
happy in my life so you say a week and a
half ago what i felt i think i was just
going through like a mental stage where
my mentor was just a bit low i felt like
all my friends were snaking me big up
yourselves
and yeah i just i didn't like the way
people was moving i just felt like i
keep putting 100 into these friendships
and relationships and i'm always getting
not even 50 back about 30 oh i could be
a bad friend as well as in like i don't
shout people every day i don't feel like
i need to communicate people every day
but that's your bad thing you would say
is that you don't really keep in common
i always check in on people and i always
ask people are you good
right people don't ask me am i good
people just ask me oh when's the next
motif people don't want to check in and
make sure i'm good you go i mean i hate
you and that's what i have a problem
with people always like were you there
on saturday but hello do you think they
use you for your name or like um i think
some people do yeah because i'm the
motive queen in it yeah yeah always got
a
what makes you happy do you think what
makes me happy waking up in the morning
being healthy
knowing my family's all that well my
family's all alive and healthy and i've
got a roof over my head a nice house i
got a nice car okay got good people
around me yeah and i'm just in a good
place in my life
so on a scale of one to ten how happy
would you say you are nine where are you
i wouldn't say ten because i feel like
there's always certain myths
you're never going to be like humans are
never satisfied in life somebody's going
to say 9.
do you say cuban no human beings
what other things are you into sports
sports and stuff like that or football
basketball you can play ball yeah
what area did you grow up in as well by
the way like hackney hackney
hackney what's that bringing in their
mirrors um you know it's not like how it
is now obviously it's gentrified now but
when i grew up it was it was a hood and
it was murder mile clapton that it was
really bare gangs bear hoods i literally
was with everyone like i was that girl i
just hung with everyone i didn't really
care where you was from to be honest
you're into music and all of that stuff
which you're asking for but was that
always something you wanted to do from
childhood do you always know that you
wanted to be an entertainer no it was a
hobby
so music was a hobby i wasn't good at it
i just like writing raps but they were
dead [ __ ]
how did you know they were dead though
did your friends tell you because i was
rapping about teletubbies
like
i didn't even want to spit it away
no you have to spit do you remember it
and this was in primary school yeah it
started then but it was just it was
banned and then it went on to secondary
school and went on to medium music as a
gcse
and even then i was dead out rapping it
just went on at me always being dead at
rapping in school but people always just
gassing it up i wanted to be a teacher
i wanted to work with kids because i
absolutely love them oh wow all right so
this is how this is how the story went
yeah so i don't music as a gcse
my teacher kept guessing me like you
need to put this on youtube it was me
singing with a little rap and i made the
beat and everything was part of my gcse
whatever i got a boom
the teacher was like put this on youtube
put on youtube it got like 10 000 views
in a month oh really this is when
twitter and things went around this was
facebook started sharing on facebook
everyone's like when are you dropping
the next tune i'm like next year then
people started popping up like can we
book you and i said book me
and it just went like that and then some
guy called teasy he had a collective
with tiga the author he's also a really
big artist and he shouted me and he was
like you want to be part of the the
clique
uh puk in the house how's that called
starting lincoln these man they taught
me how to rap
big up teasy big up tigger because they
actually taught me how to rap whatever
how do you learn that because like they
put me under their wing they took me to
every show we used to we used to do
writing sessions in my man's house
i was not allowed to leave until i wrote
a solid verse
like they were was that something right
you yeah because i was around them and
they're both hard at rapping i don't
know if you know about ticket or awful
like he's a sick rapper and a singer to
collaborate bad people they put me under
their wing and they just taught me how
to write metaphors and do what
so yeah from there i just people started
messaging me like how much to book you
for a show and i was like bro did you
even know what i was saying twenty
pounds
you could eight more months wow
twenty pound twenty five pound fifty
pounds i didn't know you don't know your
worth then yeah do you go it went from
there and i thought okay cool did you
have any inspirations yes
dynamite we got mistake
always loved
missy elliott so solid crew i'll say
them free with my missy was the one yeah
but missy elliott yeah i literally used
to go to woolworths and you know like
all her mix i mean all her albums and
singles were like parental advisory i
used to wait at woolworths and be like
excuse me could you buy this single for
me and i'd give them the money and all
of that just to get dedicated you know
we're like 299 i still got my lunch
money asked people people be like no
sorry but there was always that one
person because when i went it's weird
because when i actually now you've
mentioned all these people i kind of see
a little bit of them in here yeah did
you get on trying to miss yourself
for the tomboy
as soon as you said missy i'm sorry i
missed standing right because i thought
that
she looked like me or should i say i
look like her
okay yeah that's
you're not mad before my name was paigey
keiki it was actually hype dynamite
because i was obsessed with the woman
really yeah my email was still hyped
down in my head
and you do other things like cooking as
well don't you yeah yeah so what would
you see yourself more as what what
direction are you in because you do
loads of different things
there is no direction i think i'm just
an all-rounder now i feel like i hate
people trying to put me in a box like so
what are you but i can be what i want to
be i can't put music listen i could be a
chef that's rapping and singing
i'm doing weights at the same time i can
do what i want to do because your food
looks good
listen from time nani said it's good
it's good yeah of course you know the
nanny yeah that's that's all i need so
how did you like get into the food thing
because like your food's banging so
clearly you'd have to have been doing it
for a while now right yeah but it's like
i used to hate cooking the first thing i
ever learned my mum put me in the
kitchen she was like i'm going to teach
you how to make spaghetti bolognese
i burnt it my mom got the pot dashed it
out the ceiling all the food went on the
scene she's like you [ __ ] clean it
so from there i didn't want to learn how
to cook that my mum was mad when it
comes to things like that so i didn't
want to how to cook i was over that then
i started i got a party was kind of a
bad moment
my mom's white english my dad's black
british jamaican monster rations
[Music]
i'd like to go but yeah basically i got
a pie on waterloo road had to move to
scotland lived there for six months
scotland yeah because we filmed i filmed
for six months the
the series so while i was there i didn't
have to cook so every day i was calling
my mom like how do i had my season
my mum was telling me then every time i
was coming back i'd be at my friend's
house sydney her mom would teach me a
little one-two thing i'd call auntie how
do i do this yeah and it kind of just
went from there and it became me just
experimenting with food
when i got back i was into food and now
now yeah
like my aunt taught me a lot you never
bring my little food no
no
do you know what it is
you're gonna pay for that you've gotta
pay for that yeah mama will pay that
i'll invoice you you said yeah you could
appreciate it he said you need to pay
for my money pay for that now my flavors
are proper i don't care you
underestimate me from i would have paid
do you call all types or is it amazing
uh curry goat is my speciality she's the
main jamaican style food
jamaican soul foods
mac and cheese oxtail curry goat fried
chicken fried chicken wings raspberries
i do like
around there i do like chicken
buttermilk chicken burgers buttermilk
prawns
and you know what i like about her as
well yeah
you know what i would eat from paigey
because she looks so clean like you know
she looks it you know look at it some
people look dirty and smelly listen
i put out pictures of my kitchen on
snapchat i'm ocd
my team's clean
yeah
i love that
next minute
[Laughter]
do you have any like
goals though i do have one goal like i
really want to open a takeaway
restaurant i don't want it to be no sit
in things it's you can't pick up your
food and go because i don't want to do
the whole wait yeah
yeah so i really want to do that
um that's in the food section yeah music
yeah i'm going to continue to read it i
have to say she's not gonna use it for
food
the thing is i wanna put them together i
wanna put on events where you come to
the event and i'm also cooking
you know what i mean well i've got my
people cooking but it's still my recipe
and it's my thing
and you can skate because i'm into the
skating now so you can skate you can eat
yeah
i want to put everything so i want to be
a jack of all times
together like me got two left feet
no i'm too big to say yeah i do big
arena for that big arena
have you always skated since you was a
kid i skated yeah i've just recently got
into like proper skating
proper things like wait back in the day
i was the the guy with the free blades
you know i can't lie i was it we had the
inlines yeah
the trim with the step did you get me
the bobby brown thing so back then they
all had their little swag to it you get
me so i was just learning from a youth
man but when i see them like now doing
that i went out i went on it the other
day and i realized well i ain't got it
no more
like i've need to train again car my
friend can't see you because you're so
lumpy
yeah i'm a big guy on skates but it
works actually i'm actually going to
invite you to skating yeah i'll come
i'll come back it won't be in line
though it'll be the quad yeah the fours
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying i don't
mind doing the force the in-lighting is
amazing
it's like a line like that the walls are
in line then the four is like one two
three four i still can't even do that
four you're more steady you'll be steady
[Laughter]
what would you like in secondary school
and what school did you go to i went to
stoughton school in stoughton
the secondary school i went to i didn't
actually know anybody when i started
maybe like two people so when i started
my mom one thing i gotta say about my
mum and my dad is they always made sure
i went to school looking good so i had a
just do it back i had black jeans and
kickers so you know so i started school
already on that popular thing yeah
people's gonna want to be my friend
first day at school all the older so
like that's my younger last night yeah
because your face is different i was i
was patterned from then
and then as i got older i started
chilling with different people in school
started doing the slicks starting with
squiggles so putting the lollipops in my
hair the dice
started being bruised to the teachers
like
you seemed like a little bad breeze
don't you know what's mad i was that
girl
i would initiate all the conversations
but i'll be doing my work at the same
time so i've got a good grade because i
was proper into like i loved school i
loved learning but i was also the the
tool what was your favorite subject pee
is it yeah obviously still just yeah oh
yeah i used to love like pee and yeah he
was the one still everyone's having fun
was your sprinter in school actually 800
meters one everything no my best class
was you'd be shocked you know what it
was drama drama
i love drama i love drama i want to be
shot
did you do like
oh my classes if i'm i'm going way back
though like man's big grown man now did
you do like shakespeare entitled nah we
never did and i did not that type of
drama we weren't my school was quite
catholic so we we we it was a bit weird
but it wasn't weird like man had the
roadman in there so our drama was more
like managers playing out scenes that's
why i said to you i can improv stuff
because the drama class come back to me
you get me because that's what we did
yeah mom pretends like now paige is your
girl but she see me yeah and the man
will just play it out and everyone will
just know what they're doing it's just
mad but yeah i say i used to love that
as well yeah it's just it's just because
you didn't have drama in my school but i
did it on outside the stuff no it's
money no drama was going to school
that's mad because my school we didn't
really have re religious education oh no
we had that like we had that once every
fortnight
and we didn't have humanities didn't you
no we had that year seven and eight and
then they scrapped it
so we didn't learn i don't even know
what humanities is to be artistic
that's not re we didn't learn about
religious education and when we did it
was always arguing because we had so
many different faiths and religious
people people in our class is this are
you religious no i'm spiritual oh
spiritual do you believe in god then i
believe in god but i just don't you know
what i'm glad you said that i don't read
like i just don't read too far into it
but i i believe there's a higher power
but i'm more on the spiritual thing but
i feel like it's all the same like
people for example that read the bible
they believe that if you ask god for
something you're going to get it that's
just manifestation yeah that's all it is
i like to manifest things and it comes
my way so it's the same thing so you see
the secret then oh yeah of course i
watched the visual recognition where
you're talking she just sounds like
she's in the same zone as me yeah i
understand everything i've got in my
life
yeah you have to that's banging still
i'm glad that you do that still you left
school and then
i went college and i dropped out what
did you study in college well i thought
i was getting peer pressure by my
friend's mom and my mom to do business
oh business oh stop it
did you help no someday in business i'm
doing psychology
and drama
love drama love psychology business
couldn't understand it
and i was like this isn't for me dropped
out ended up getting a part anyways in
the film then i attacked the block so
therefore i was making money from that
thing yeah i played dimples i killed the
alien and whatnot no the girls and they
will come together
you know isn't it i need to watch that
yeah i was telling me about attacking
the block
yeah i was the main girl me and danielle
no i'm going to go watch that tonight
zoom up there's pagey lock i did not in
the vids yeah how old was you when you
did that um i think i was 18. see
yes i left college and literally done
that
because i was getting paid how did you
get it did you do right not for it or
did something no so i used to do like
little drama classes on like six weeks
holidays so i was doing like this
performing arts project so it's like
singing and dancing acting some casting
director came in she was like you and
your friends are dope she would
like oh you and your friends are amazing
yeah fantastic would love for you to
come down
to the open workshops
me and my friends are like yeah we're
gonna go you know looking at you like
what the [ __ ] you
the day came we meant to go to the
workshop my friend said they don't want
to come so i'm like i went by myself not
knowing that me going to that workshop
opened the door and i got an audition
i've done about
yeah but i didn't realize i actually had
the part from the first audition the
director why did they make you do now
just to make it look authentic right
like we went through the stages yeah i'm
going to read a statement with everyone
but i was the only person that actually
sent the script on the first thing
because he already knew i was just
patterned and you know why he picked me
because he said he liked the swagger
yeah i came with the rope chain the pink
air force the pink jumper so he's always
dressing isn't everyone coming suit and
tie and when i turned a puzzle oh my god
i didn't know i was meant to dress like
in a shirt what did you do i got a shirt
and i came in a big roach hay and yeah
all right so your relationship status
obviously you have girlfriends yeah
are you lesbian or are you bi or you
just
no i'm bisexual right in the last let's
say
maybe
five years i've dated two girls right
like i'm currently dating a girl now
right yeah um
this is just all new as well but before
that yeah i dated guys
but i don't know do you know what i'm
gonna be honest
one thing about one thing about guys is
they're not as affectionate
maybe i've been made it wrong
i think that a lot of women that are
lesbians yeah they just don't have a man
that knows how to deal with them proper
no but i just saw that so you have the
powers then yes man i can convert a
lesbian i'm telling you we're saying
[Applause]
my thing is the right person just has to
come and i'm there i don't care you
could be alien
but honestly guys are not as
affectionate as women and i'm a bit
honest the only thing i miss from a guy
is being treated like i'm spending it
opening the door doing all these things
in a female relationship it's not really
like that really yeah so
yeah so i'm just like the tradition
traditional kind of a man should do that
standard if you could do if you if you
do that for your mom you'll do that for
your sister you do you know i mean
family relatives why can't you do that
for your girlfriend you get me i
never always do on the first date though
because you're trying to get somewhere
really yeah that's the same saying
that's the first date thingy let's go
back to the gala no mandom thing because
i want to deep it because they set a man
out there watching now and women we
probably want to know certain things so
we've got paigey here and we can ask
these questions this is what i like here
i'm saying
yeah so we know what size it works so
what what are you saying if a guy takes
you out on a first date is it right that
he pays that milk
just absolutely honest i don't really
care about the pain thank you
you don't need them
i don't know i don't look for man see
he did man got the everything the milk
all of it more food added more food to
the meal because he saw her snap through
something else's and he saw himself
done a bad way move he's gone yeah cool
do what she wants yeah get that bam said
he's been
he was calling him going what's going on
where are you i'm here at the table you
hit the table i'll do your thing you
boops man don't you
guys
i don't know what happened today reverse
the girls have been sat there looking at
the bill like
one bad song or something stupid so what
is the situation with you and david
bummy because people like to ask
you i always see you together david's my
guy like
went on holiday came out for my birthday
how did you meet
did he move to you or what could you not
say you know i met david time ago at um
i can't remember what brand it was but
we got invited to a dinner i met him
there he was sitting across from me
spoke pulling him on inside follow me on
instagram let me just yeah we just how
how long have you known it terrifying
probably a couple of few years ago so
it's always just been a friendship tim
yeah and he's just like a proper papa
cool guy she's telling me once moved to
you
because it's hard yeah you see
because it's hard like you're pretty
girl maybe and it's hard when my man
chats to you
majority of time they're going to try
and move to you they're not going to oh
yeah i want to be her friend
math would be real i might have to be
ruined it black man is man woman is
woman in it yeah so we both know our
needs we know we get me and obviously
there's a there's a line you don't go
past or whatever cool but as bedrooms if
i'm attracted to this skeleton attracted
to me stuff's gonna happen of course off
the cards yes whether i tell you or not
that's down there you never know but
trust me man of man
might not have to put abc together to
know what guang for the rest to get me
so if they did
is what stays behind the pages will stay
back and the pages it's easy to call
this guy because i see on like a lot i
don't know him i don't know not i'm
about him but every time i go to the
comment section people say he's arrogant
he's
cool guy he's actually really quiet i
can imagine he just got up you've just
got an eye to take him yeah he's got an
attitude like that like
yeah
sometimes it can be off-key for the ones
who can't handle it yeah yeah cause he's
awkward i thought he moved really i
thought
you do you know what scared me the most
is when i heard him speak when i first
heard him speak he's actually properly
disguised
you really
his background is
and i think a lot of people clock that
in him like you talk and move a certain
way with certain crowds and you'd think
that man's going to be like yo
he's not that guy he's like he's more
mate you know what and what is it what
is it he does like because i i like i
said i don't follow he just does fashion
he just like i'll say he's like a
fashion influencer
obviously he makes his bread but yeah
you know like he just he just puts on
lit outfits and just that guy in it
lives life yeah
oh he's got a maggie on him
pick up david don't pick him up still
because we've got david
he's madden man he's madden
all right so you made the music colleen
and you made a tune oh i think it was
like 10 months ago right
and it's called um
our little secret or secret i think it's
called secret yeah yeah it's called
secret
now this
is kind of like a i think an important
subject that we need to speak about
because
it's tough
and there's a lot of people out there a
lot of our souls out there
that's doing some sort of thing with
these younger girls and you know and
it's turning them a certain way
now if you just explain a bit what that
tune's about
i won't go into it because it's your
tune yeah so basically the song's called
the secret or secret and um it was it's
basically me telling the story of what
happened to me when i was about five so
my mom had this boyfriend and one day my
mom fell asleep on the sofa we was all
watching that star trek my mom fell
asleep on her so far you said was it me
my mum and dad and him yeah my mom fell
asleep on the sofa and he just began
touching me like
in mad places and i'm i'm a child and
then he was like don't tell your mum
don't tell your mom obviously because
i'm a child i was just you didn't know
what yeah i knew it was wrong but it's
like he told me not to say no and i was
scared in this i didn't tell him i
didn't say that to my mom till i was
about like nine and what did you do and
i broke down crying my mom always had
this this thing that she used to say
if anyone ever touches you or says
anything inappropriate you tell me and
every time she said it i wanted to tell
her i didn't have to tell her so then
one day i just told her and i was just
crying and what made you scared to tell
her is it because of what he he said
yeah he said don't tell your mum and it
was like you know when you're a child it
just happened now are you mad he'd be
dead yeah but it's like
it happened when you're five your brain
don't process information like how it
does when you're older so if someone
tells you not to do something you're
either going to do it or you're not
going to do it he told me not to decide
yes i thought maybe i'll get in trouble
for saying it when was it was it was it
repeated what did he do no he only ever
done it one time but it was like after
that one time now that i'm older my
mom's told me from there i started
moving a bit weird
with him which i didn't know when you
broke down when he was nine
um what did your mom what was your mom's
reaction to was she she was a guy no she
was not with him she was just mad
shocked and like
it's just something like from nine till
what i had a court case about it when i
was about 20 23 24 oh you took him to
court good took him to court
and it's like so that whole time nothing
had been done about it my mom didn't
even tell my dad because my dad would be
in prison for killing the man of course
so it's like we've done it the proper
way and went to court and whatnot and
did he get done for him this is the
thing because it happened so long ago
ain't no evidence
he only got like two years on a sex
you know that on there on that one let
me tell you something sex effect what
did you get
yeah like he didn't really get nothing
so he didn't go to jail for it no he
didn't go to he just got on the sex
offender yeah
he said he read the secret and he's got
a lot of [ __ ] comments
if not now
it's
touching off of that subject here
because it is very very very very very
important
um
yeah sorry to hear that and i've i
didn't know this about anything you know
i mean and i've got a daughter who's 12.
so
she watches you a lot i do what you do
as well so
i'm glad you've shared that story with
everyone anyway because other girls out
there your age you know i mean they
might not they might be going through
the same thing now yeah and not talking
so honestly that is why i've put the
video out
i'm just trying to be as transparent so
what would you say
what is your message to the kids you
know i would just say to all the younger
people younger girls like if you're ever
going through something in life just
remember there is always somebody you
can talk to whether that be friends
family member a teacher even like a
hotline like a art frank or a helpline
there's always somebody don't ever shut
yourself off and never feel like you're
just going through this by yourself
because there's always someone else
going through something similar or
something the same and that's one reason
why i like to use my platform to like
promote these type of messages so people
know they're not alone what i'll also
say is do not be scared to tell someone
because what these guys do they try to
threaten you
but remember
their word is is is your word over this
so if you go and tell on this guy he's
going to be in a worse position than you
are so don't ever feel scared to come
out and say yo this guy's been doing
whatever whatever because i'm sure he's
going to get it and he'll be here coming
near you after that do you go i'm saying
he's shocked now i [ __ ] need it too
but they manipulate you to make you
think that you can't say nothing but you
gotta remember you're more powerful
you're more powerful than this person
exactly even though they'll make you
feel like you're not okay
so paige do you find it difficult being
a woman in the industry i'm not a woman
i'm a goat
so we went quick anyway
she changed the whole setting i know
what that means girl of all talents
when i came into the industry it was
hard being a female but it was all about
there weren't much like female rappers
when i first was the man a minute no we
only had lab
yeah
what did you say um when you first come
up yeah like miss brat lioness nolo
um lady lisa trying to think baby blue
yeah they they were all out during that
time when i was like coming out but it
was only hard because it was just it was
more like a male dominated scene
no black female had really made their
mark apart from miss dynamite
oh yeah yeah true and estelle but she
went to america but like only them two
females are saying m.i.a whatever it was
a struggle like no one was taking me
serious
people was just writing some dumb stuff
on my
videos that
just doesn't look like the kitchen
you know that that
trolls man
i'm doing a freestyle in the street and
they're saying it just doesn't look like
the kitchen
make me a sandwich while you're out here
it was all them dumb
did that depress you did that make you
stressed like how did you deal with it
because you seemed pretty like confident
now you call yourself the goal that all
comes with time beginning of my career i
used to cry my eyes out i'm probably the
person that's been dragged the most on
social media so i feel like it's made my
skin a lot thicker than most so do we
comment still no not at all yeah so i
don't read comments i only read some
comments on my pictures like just the
first set and then i know what you're
looking for
but like other than that i do not read
comments i don't care what the comment
says because i don't want to see it
because it'll put me in a [ __ ] mood if
i'm in a good mood sometimes
i do find myself sometimes i'm in that
mood if someone comes to me i'm going to
come for you but i kind of stopped doing
that i'm just so really your skin is
sort of thick because it's sort of it
would be
thick if you could read it and be like
yeah possible
but you know what it's like even the
other day when i was getting dragged on
all these gossip pages my whole
mentality is i spend in a month what you
make in a year i just keep telling
myself that if i tell them if i tell
myself like cocky thoughts i feel better
what are you doing with your life
you're here commenting remember that
that is dead in your fake profiles
paigey has been amazing
it's been fun i'm glad i got to know you
more as a person as well because i
always see you seeing your team
we bonded well man so i'm glad i got to
know you because like i said i always
see you doing bare things yeah [ __ ]
yeah i'm saying so i'm like what is
pagey about so now i've got to
understand you now it's been very good
and for the people as well that's been
like me
and how you've seen paigey hopefully now
you can get to understand more about
that
yeah
all right listen
that was the end of the waffle yeah
waffle waffle whatever you want one draw
us
see us yeah next week next week again i
don't know who we've got next week
i think it's some tall brothers
yeah
[Applause]
you